always a pleasure to see you you know or
let me say I am a big fan of your work
uh and you are great in this this is
just what we call a really really really
good
movie I feel like it is too man I'm I'm
really happy to be in it it is a really
good movie it really is like I have
nothing but positive things to say but
listen there's going to be people out
there who've never seen anything you've
done before so besides this movie which
obviously everyone should see what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why oh wow that's interesting um how
about um well if you're watching flora
and sun on Apple TV plus I'm not saying
it because of them but I made a show
called Mr cormet that also came out on
Apple a couple years ago and uh I wrote
a lot of it and directed A lot of it and
it's um it's a weird little it's also
kind of suany you know flora and sun
came out of of Sundance Mr Corman never
played at Sundance but it it it's very
much in that Spirit of kind of like
weird '90s Indie movies in a in a half
hour dramedy and uh I'm very very proud
of it and um yeah watch that one so you
have done so many cool things in your
career and I'm just curious what was the
project that before you stepped on set
the first day you think you were
probably the most nervous to play that
role ah that's interesting
well um I don't get easily nervous
uh playing opposite Daniel D Lewis and
Lincoln was pretty exciting um hosting
SNL was very
nerve-wracking um that's not exactly a
role in a movie but but actually and I'm
not just saying this like flora and sun
because I'm I'm singing and playing
guitar in
it I was way more nervous for those
scenes than I usually am for
a sh uh because I've always wanted to
make music in a movie and this is really
kind of the first time I got to and uh
and so i' had been practicing and
singing and um we we shot some of these
scenes in a sort of unconventional way
usually for a musical you go and sing in
a studio and you do lots of takes and
they edit together the best pieces of
all the takes and then when you shoot
you lip
to what you sang before um and we did do
that on some of the songs but on some of
the songs we just recorded them for real
when it was just like me singing and
playing guitar and there wasn't other
stuff going on and uh so those days were
I definitely had some nerves which again
is like kind of irregular for me but to
just sit there and sing a whole song and
play it with no accompaniment and no
editing or anything um that challenged
me in in a very thrilling way but uh but
it was a challenge so I am a big fan of
John Carney just like you and just like
so many people and I am just curious
when um you found out you could work
with him like how much did you pay him
to be in the movie I had to convince him
it's really true uh because he initially
was thinking that this role should be
played by a musician like a a great
well-known professional musician
and I wrote him a whole letter about how
like man I'm telling you you don't want
a big golden
voiced Rockstar to play this part you
want an actor and you want like kind of
a normal guy who can sing and who can
play and I'll sing and I'll play and
I'll practice and I'll do it all well
but but who's more a little grounded and
down to earth and more than anything
just feels uh like like a real person
that's what what's going to make this
character really pop and uh luckily I
was able to convince him of that you're
by the way you're 100% right because if
some big name had been in the role it it
honestly I don't think it would have
worked for me I think it's because
you're playing a normal person right
right right you know so you you guys
premiered at uh Sundance and then you
were one of the big sales and went to
Apple I think actually this movie is
perfect at Apple I think it just it's
it's a it's a great fit but what was it
like for you um you know uh premiering
at Sundance and having it sell like you
know what I mean it's really cool it we
had the quintessential Sundance
experience I've I've had it been lucky
to have it a few times in my career and
uh like it happened with uh brick which
was Ryan Johnson's first movie or 500
Days of Summer was a little different
because it was already at Fox Search
light and and wasn't playing uh as a um
it wasn't playing in competition it
already been sold Don John was another
one um we made that as an independent
movie without distribution and you know
had that night where like people first
saw it and then buyers were coming at us
and we're like thank God buyers want to
buy it and who should we and that whole
experience that you've heard of uh it
was a real thrill to get to live it and
with flora and Sun it was the same and I
I also want to say you're absolutely
right it it really fits at Apple and um
like I said I did another show at Apple
and and having them you know with this
movie they
they really have a slightly different
mentality than a lot of the other big
streamers and and frankly I think it's
because they don't make their money with
movies they make their money with phones
so their thing is more about like let's
let's actually just make sure that the
stuff is kind of like has an Integrity
to it and is and is beautiful and good
and um let's respect the artists there's
a tradition at Apple of like kind of
respecting individuals as opposed to
just looking at like like data and
market research and things like that and
um I I've had a really good experience
at Apple I'm glad to have this movie
there I mean this sincerely and I think
some of the other streamers will get mad
at me for saying this but if uh if I had
to cancel my streamers I would keep
apple like I I really love the Sci-Fi
they're making um and like they just
make really good stuff and I that's what
I really think it's a great fit well
thank you for saying so I mean I'm I'm
not them but I thank you on their behalf
yeah no totally so uh two quick things
one uh you are were a great host at SNL
uh espe there's I could pinpoint a whole
bunch of skits and the opening monologue
but um any plans on going back to that
yeah call him up tell him tell him the
the guy from Flor and son wants to
host okay and my last thing for you
because I got a wrap uh I know your
relationship with Ryan uh have you been
talking about possibly you know um
Knives Out Three I no the answer is no
okay I would like that to happen on that
note I'm just gonna say man I really
enjoy your work like I said at the
beginning really happy for you congrats
on this film and uh have a fantastic day
thanks so much great to talk to you man
as
always